Rất giãn nhở cho thuy kuy mồ lớn của thành phố gồm, giãn đầu tư sây dựng nhở cho thuê thành phố tại
cuối lúc thị mới pháp văn tự nghiệp, giãn đầu tư sây dựng nhở cho thuê thành phố
tại phần viên hơn. Rất giãn cu nhở hỗn hợp, gi馬 mông biên, bên cạnh đó,
ninh giãn nhở thồng gồm công ty của phần viên gồm và công ty của phần đầu tư và phát triển
đường sách cao toc, viên speed đã được lửa cho at là tổng thầu EPC cho nâm giãn đường
sách đồ thi mới tại thủ đô, chiến cơ sở về chủi về năng lực lội tại, cũng mạng lưỡi đối tác là các công ty hàng đầu thị dưới.
Năm giãn đường sách đồ thi, gắn mới phát triển lỗi thi theo mô hình đô thi điển gướng rau thông công công,
với tổng mức đồ tư hơn 18 triệu thì đồng. Đây là nước quan trọng trong lộ trình phát triển mạng lưỡi rau thông viện đại của Hanoi,
nước cao lắm lực vận tại hành khách thông cộng khối lượng lưỡn, giãn muốn tắc và khai thác hiểu qua quyết đo thị,
đồng thời tạo dưới đi ở tăng triệu mới cho thủ đô dài đoạn hành hiểu không trong ngày sáo hành hiểu không trong bà mười.
Tặc biệt, giãn sẽ mở giống khu dân phát triển các hành lăng mắt nâm, đồng thời,
kết nối xong vai nội bài gà hành lỗi, mời các cử tăng triệu mới như hoa lạc, thưa lâm, của loa, ra lâm,
và các đợp thương trong vùng thủ đô, qua đỏ nân cao năng lực linh kết vùng tăng xức cạnh tranh và tạo lực tăng triệu mới cho thủ đô trong nhiều thập biến tới.
Phát biểu tại sự kiện, chú tích ở bán ngân thánh của hành lỗi bú đại tháng khẳng liền,
lấy hợi cầu ngon này là bước đi của thề nhằm đương nghỉ quyết số 2 của bổ trín trị,
loa thủ đô, các đồng thời thủ đô và các kết chế chính xét đặc thủ của chúng ngân đi vào thủ tiến.
Đồng thời, thế hiện quyết tâm của hành lỗi trong việc sử dụng hiểu của hành những kết chế đã được giao để tạo ra các độc lực tăng triệu mới,
các khùng gián phát triệu mới và những giá triệu mới cho người dân thủ đô.
Đối với các giả nhẹ ở cho thề, đồng chi muốn đại tháng cho biết,
đây là những giả nổ tiền trong trình trình phát triển nhạy cho thề của thành phố,
tạo tiên đe để tương bước thình thành một khân khúc nhợ mới,
đá bởi như cầu ngay cảnh đa dạng của người dân,
một tiêu của thành phố là tương bước thình thành thị trường nhợ cho thề truyền nghiệp,
chất lượng cao giá cả phủ hợp.
Đồng thời có phần giảm áp lực sử dụng hiền nhà bằng mọi giá,
sây dựng thị trường bất động sản phát triển lạnh mạnh,
bình bấm và phủ hợp giới sư thế phát triển của thế,
tại sự kiện thù đường chính phủ lấy mình hơn và các đồng chi lánh đào các bộ ngành chung hương thành phố Hà Nội.
Và có đại diện ra nghiệp đã thực hiện như thức chính thức tởi con các con trình.